so I hear you love Nashville you love
stopping and I'm obsessed with Nashville
I'm gonna be on national on the tour I
love going to Nashville because of the
vintage short stores yes they have the
best vintage shopping but I think I
might stop doing it because last time I
went I got this like awesome denim
jacket it had all these like patches on
it and pins and I wore it all the time
on Instagram like I have a horse and you
know I ride my horse in this jacket and
I loved it so much and I got this DM one
day from this guy who was like hey my ex
got mad at me and sold a bunch of my
stuff to a vintage store that's awesome
how am I not thought of that
that is amazing you're you're trashing
your stuff plus making progress
this woman is an entrepreneur and she
sounds awesome and Sue say can I have it
back and I was like yeah I guess I set
it back did you tell him for this amount
of money sorry she's a turd so that and
then the other thing about going to the
south is I'm still trying to figure out
like what everything means and you can
probably help me with the southern
colloquialisms yes
what does bless your heart mean doesn't
it means you're stupid
well writers there's like it depends on
the tone yeah well you're saying it to
okay so when I go to the South they'll
ask me where I'm from and I'm like I
live in LA and they're like bless your
heart
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's another curse William of being
shady doesn't it sound like it's like
British people cursing you out like it's
rude but I like it yeah yeah and then I
learned the hard way that when a woman
set in the South says she's fixing to
pitch a fit I'm fixing a pitch up [ __ ]
get out of there get out of there yep
and grab anything that belongs to
because she'll sell it to I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this